in this video we're going to be doing
some rounding which you're probably not
familiar with just yet but you'll see
that it's pretty straight forward and
we're going to start by rounding to the
nearest ten so the first question is
what is rounding and why is it even
useful well let's say that you have the
number 37 it's a fine number but let's
say that you have to do some math with
the number 37 and you can do a lot of
math with the number 37 but let's say
you just want to estimate what something
might be let's say that someone says hey
I have 37 pickles and you have 39
pickles roughly how many do we have
together we don't have to have it down
to the exact number of pickles well then
rounding will actually be a very useful
tool but let's just focus on what it
means to round to the nearest 10 so when
they're talking about rounding to the
nearest 10 we're going to be thinking
about the tens place of the number so we
can see right over here in our tens
place we have a three and so that three
represents three tens so the number 37
it's three tens and 7 ones so it is more
than three tens and it's going to be
less than four tens so this number is
going to be more than three tens I could
do it like this it's going to be more
than three tenths which we can represent
like that three tens is your ones or you
might know that as 30 and it's going to
be less than four tens or also known as
40 and so when you're rounding you're
either going to round to the number of
tens that is right below this number or
the number of tens that is right above
that but how do we know whether 37
rounded to the nearest 10 is going to be
30 or 40 well to answer that question
let's first just do it visually on a
number line and then we can come up with
some rules for ourselves and so first of
all let's just count by tens and to make
sure we include 30 and 40 so if we start
at 0 10 20 actually let me have a little
bit more space
because I want to see the interesting
things that are going to go on 0 10 20
30 40 that's enough but I could just go
to 50 just to complete this number line
and so where is 37 on this number line
well it's between 30 and 40 and if I
wanted to make it a little bit clearer
if I said that this is 35 right over
there right in between 30 and 40 then 37
is going to be right about right about
here so that is 37 and so when you're
rounding to the nearest 10 and remember
we're picking between three tens and
four tens you say which 10 is it closest
to is it closer to three tens or is it
closer to four tens well you can just
look at this and say hey it looks a lot
closer to four tens and so in this
situation 37 rounded to the nearest 10
is going to be 40 and so you might ask a
question well give me another number
what if someone said 32 rounded to the
nearest ten well 32 is going to be right
over here and then you'd say all right
well that's between three tens and four
tens but it's a lot closer to three tens
so 32 rounded to the nearest ten is
going to be is going to be 30 now an
interesting question that you might be
wondering is what if you're right in
between what if we wanted around 35 to
the nearest 10 35 once again it's
between three tens and four tens between
30 and 40 which one do we round to if we
want to round to the nearest ten well
the rule is and this is really just
something that the society has decided
on is that if you're right in the middle
you round up so the number 35 is going
to round up to 40 even though it's
exactly five away from each of these
numbers 35 if you're right in between is
going to round up to 40 if you're a
little bit less than 35 then you're
going to ground down to 30
but with that out of the way let's do
some more examples let's do actually
let's do an example of a three-digit
number we're we're rounding to the
nearest tenth
let's say that we want to round the
number 124 to the nearest ten well you
could there's a couple of ways that you
could think about this you could say
that this is one hundred two tens and
four ones or you could even view this as
twelve tens and four ones so you could
say hey this is in between twelve twelve
tens and four ones it's greater than
twelve tens which is a hundred and
twenty and it's less than thirteen tens
which is one hundred and thirty
these are the two tens that are closest
to this number and then to decide which
one it rounds to you might already be
able to think about it based on some of
the rules we came up with but let me
draw it on a number line for you so let
me draw a number line and I'm not going
to start at zero because we ought we
have to get all the way to a hundred and
thirty so let's just start I'll start at
a hundred so this is one hundred one
hundred and ten let me draw the number
line we're going to have one hundred and
twenty then we go to one hundred and
thirty I'll just do one hundred forty
here just for filling out the number
line that I've drawn so far and then
I'll draw the halfway mark which is 125
and then see it's halfway it's maybe a
little bit closer to there and then 124
let me do it in this red color 124 is
right over there
124 and so for trying to pick between
120 and 130 between twelve tens and
thirteen tens which one is it closer to
well we can see it's only four away from
120 while it's six away from 130 so we
would round down we're going to round
down to a hundred and twenty in this
situation if we're rounding to the
nearest ten if this was 125 or 126 127
our 28th 129 well then we would round to
130 and of course if it was 130 we would
round it to
130 let's do one more example and
actually I'm going to do a one digit
number let's say we want around seven to
the nearest ten I'll write it out around
seven to the nearest nearest ten pause
this video and see if you can do that
all right well seven is between what two
tens well seven is less than 110 so it's
less than 110 and it's greater than zero
tens so it's between zero tens which is
just zero and one 10 which is 10 but
which one does it round to well here
once again we can draw our number line
so we'll do zero and then this is 5 and
then this is 10 and 7 is right about
there
that is where 7 is and we can either
visually see that 7 is closer to 10 than
it is to 0 it's only 3 away from 10
while it's 7 away from 0 so you would
round up to 10 or you can use the rule
that we just thought about 7 is greater
than or equal to 5 so you round up you
round to the 10 that is higher than this
number if this number was if in the ones
place I can say if your ones place is
between 0 it's greater than or equal to
0 but less than 5 then you round down
and you can see that happens in all of
these situations if you looked at 37 you
look at the ones place and your ones
place here is greater than or equal to 5
so you round up here if your ones place
it's greater than or equal to 5 it's 5
exactly in that situation so it's equal
to 5 once again you round up if your
ones place is less than 5 well in this
situation we round down if your ones
place is less than 5 you round down your
ones place and here you only have a ones
place but it's greater than or equal to
5 we rounded up